silent Hills may have been cancelled but
it looks like walking dead star norman
reedus and Metal Gear Solid creator
Hideo Kojima still keep in touch the two
met up last night to talk about kojima's
new company it's unclear exactly what
they discussed but we can only hope it's
a reimagining of the ideas behind silent
Hills kojima is in Las Vegas this week
for an appearance at the dice summit he
will be joined by director Guillermo del
Toro to deliver the summit's keynote
address in addition Kojima will be
inducted into dices Hall of Fame it
wasn't just del Toro and Rita's that
Kojima apparently wanted to collaborate
with for the new Silent Hill game a
title he said would be so scary that it
would make you want to get your pants
years aboard creator cliff bleszinski
recently said that kojima asked him to
work on a silent Hills game but he
ultimately declined as for the Silent
Hill series konami has said it is
committed to new Silent Hill titles
though no future games have been
announced we will have editors on the
ground in Las Vegas bringing you the
latest news as it's announced so stay
tuned to gamespot
you